[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادي الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبداها من اوديسا في اوكرانيا التي تقول
انها تعرضت لهجوم روسي بالمسيرات تزامنا
مع هجوم مماثل على منشات في ميناء اوكراني
مطل على الدانوب
ثم الى الخرطوم حيث نفى الجيش السوداني اي
حديث عن هدنه مشيرا الى ان المساره
التفاوضيه متوقف بينما حذر الدعم السريع
من حرب الاهليه
ومن واشنطن والمشهد بعد حاله قلق امني
خارج الكابيتول يقول مصدر من شرطه العاصمه
انه لم يتم العثور على اي شخص مسلح في
مبنى الكونجرس وان انذار الطوارئ جاء بناء
على اتصال كاذب
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد قصف الروسي لميناء اوكراني على نهر
الدانوب ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب في العالم
زيلينسكي يقول ان روسيا تريد انهيار اسواق
الغذاء والامدادات وبوتين يؤكد لاردوغان
استعداده للعوده لاتفاق الحبوب اذا تحققت
شروطه
محادثات لمجموعه في النيجر دول غرب
افريقيا تقول ان التدخل العسكري هو الخيار
الاخير المجلس العسكري في النيجر يعيد فتح
الحدود البريه والجويه مع خمس دول ويرسل
مبعوثا الى مالي واجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
يتواصل بوتيره سريعه
وزير الخارجيه الافغاني يصف في مقابله مع
الجزيره المفاوضات مع الوفد الامريكي في
الدوحه بالايجابيه ويؤكد ان بلاده لن تسمح
باستخدام اراضيها ضد الاخرين ويدعو واشنطن
لرفع العقوبات
وسط جدل قانوني الرئيس التونسي يعين رئيسا
جديدا للحكومه ويؤكد اولويه مواجهه ما
وصفه باللوبيات الساعيه لتجويع الشعب جبهه
الخلاص تشكك في قانونيه اقاله رئيسه
الحكومه السابقه وتتهم السلطات بانكار
حقيقه الازمه الاقتصاديه للبلاد
الامم المتحده تدق ناقوس خطر في السودان
وتحذر من ان سته ملايين شخص باتوا على شفا
المجاعه ومع تصاعد المعارك حظر للتجوال في
ولايه الشمال كردفان غربي البلاد والدعم
السريع يحذر من حرب اهليه في شرقها والجيش
يؤكد توقف مسار التفاوض وينفي الحديث عن
هدنه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد وكما جرت
العاده ناقشنا معكم عبر منصاتنا الرقميه
سياقه اعلام الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
اقاله رئيسه الحكومه نجلاء بودن وتعيين
احمد الحشالي بدلا منها باستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع قلنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم ماده واسع وراء
اقاله الرئيس التونسي رئيسه الحكومه جاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي 40% قالوا انها
للتاكيد على صلاحيات النظام الرئاسي بينما
قال
35% ان السبب يعود لعدم تلبيه نجلاء بودن
للطموحات اما 25% فقالوا انها للتحضير
لانتخابات الرئاسه المقبله
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات
الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا وكذلك دوليه
ايضا تتابعون في هذا الحصاد وفي مقابله
خاصه للجزيره مبعوث الامم المتحده الى
ليبيا يشدد على مشاركه الاطراف كافه في
عمليه سياسيه من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق
شامل
[موسيقى]
السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت ان مسيرات روسيه
استهدفت ميناء اسماعيل احد اكبر الموانئ
النهريه للحبوب في اوكرانيا ويقع على نهر
الدانوب على الحدود مع رومانيا في مقاطعه
اوديسا وقال المتحدث باسم الاداره
العسكريه في مدينه اوديسا ان الهجوم اوقع
اضرارا بالمناء وصوامع الحبوب
لم تتوقف روسيا عن ضرب منشات تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه منذ انسحابها من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب في منتصف الشهر الماضي يستمر هذا
القصف رغم اعلان موسكو استعدادها للعوده
للاتفاق بشروط في بيان بعد اتصال هاتفي
بين الرئيسين الروسي والتركي اكد الكرملين
استعداده للعوده فورا الى اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب اذا نفذ الغرب كل التزاماته لروسيا
اذا تترك روسيا الباب مفتوحا للعوده الى
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب لكنها لم تتوقف عن ضرب
البنيه التحتيه التي ستحتاج اليها
اوكرانيا لتصدير حبوبها اذا جرى احياء
الاتفاق تركزت الهجمات مباشره بعد انسحاب
روسيا من الاتفاق على اهم موانئ اوكرانيا
على البحر الاسود وخصوصا ميناء اوديسا
الاستراتيجي ثم بدات في ضرب موانئ بديله
على نهر الدانوب فقاسفت ميناء ريني في
الرابع والعشرين من الشهر الماضي والان
تقصف اسماعيل ما تسبب حسب السلطات
الاوكرانيه في اتلاف اربعين الف طن من
الحبوب تقول كياف ان هدف موسكو من هذه
الهجمات واقناع شركات السفن وشركات
التامين ان كل الموانئ الاوكرانيه غير
امنه لكن السلطات الاوكرانيه تؤكد
استمرارها في البحث عن بدائل لموانئها في
البحر الاسود المحاصره من قبل روسيا تشكل
الموانئ الاوكرانيه على نهر الدانوب الذي
يقع على حدود اوكرانيا ورومانيا افضل
البدائل رغم ان مياه النهر الضحله مقارنه
بمياه البحر الاسود تستدعي استخدام سفن
اصغر وباعداد اكبر تنقل الحبوب من الموانئ
النهريه الاوكرانيه على الدنوب الى ميناء
كونستانتا الروماني على البحر الاسود في
عام 2022 صدرت ثمانيه ملايين الف طن من
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر الميناء الروماني
لم يتوقف بحث اوكرانيا عن البدائل فقد
اعلن الاوكراني اتفاقا مع كرواتيا بشان
امكانيه تصدير الحبوب عبر موانئ كرواتيا
على الدانوب وبحر الادرياتيك ورغم دورها
المحدود وعرقله استخدامها من قبل الفلاحين
الاوروبيين الرافدين لاستقبال الحبوب
الاوكرانيه تبقى الطرق البريه بديلا اخر
لتصدير حبوب اوكرانيا لكن هذه البدائل وان
تعددت لا تغني عن البحر الاسود الذي يبقى
اسهل الطرق واقلها تكلفه لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه
في ردود الفعل الغربيه قال مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قال ان روسيا تواصل هجماتها الجويه على
كييف واوديسا وموانئ الدانوب الاوكرانيه
وتعرض الملايين من الفئات الاكثر ضعفا
تعرضهم للخطر وحذر بوريل من ان الهجمات
الروسيه على البنيه التحتيه للحبوب
الاوكرانيه ستؤدي الى تفاقم انعدام الامن
الغذائي العالمي اما السفير الامريكيه في
كييف فقالت ان الهجمات التصعيديه الروسيه
على البنيه التحتيه تمثل هجوما شاملا على
قدره اوكرانيا على تصدير الحبوب وقالت
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان روسيا تعرض الامن
الغذائي العالمي للخطر عمدا
في مقابله مع الجزيره قال مسعود حقي جاشين
عضو مجلس الامن والسياسات الخارجيه التابع
للرئاسه التركيه ان المحادثات بين اردوغان
وبوتين تاتي في وقت تتصاعد فيه المواجهات
او المخاوف عفوا من مواجهه عسكريه في
البحر الاسود بين روسيا واوكرانيا مؤكدا
امكانيه عوده روسيا الى اتفاق الحبوب
تريد تركيا استئناف العمل باتفاقيه الحبوب
لكن كما تعلمون فان روسيا سحبت ضباطها من
مركز التنسيق المشترك في اسطنبول لروسيا
ثلاثه مطالب كي تعود للاتفاق هناك خط
انابيب للامونيا الروسيه وتريد ان يباع
السماد الروسي والحبوب الروسيه للعالم
وتريد ايضا اعاده بنك الزراعه الروسي
للنظام سويفت العالمي اما عسكريا فان
محادثات بوتين اردوغان لها اهميه في ظل
مخاوف من حرب اساطير بين روسيا واوكرانيا
في البحر الاسود خصوصا ان الطرفين اعلن ان
سفن الطرف الاخر اهداف المشروعه
معنا من بوخارست سيزر جورج وهو مدير مؤسسه
اجري كورمان لاستشارات سوق الحبوب من
منطقه البحر الاسود اهلا بك
هذه العمليه الاخيره في ميناء بنهر
الدانوب من اسماعيل
هل ستؤثر على فكره ان تكون رومانيا احدى
البدائل لاخراج وايصال الحبوب الاوكرانيه
في الحقيقه
اصبحت البديله الاهم للبضائع الاوكرانيه
منذ عشيه الحرب في الموسم الماضي وفي سته
عشر شهرا الماضيه كان هناك اكثر من 20
مليون طن مرت عبر اراضينا اذا لا يوجد شيء
جديد هنا نحن سوف نستمر من الان فصاعدا
للتقديم الدعم لصادرات البضائع الاوكرانيه
لانها هذا البديل الروماني هو الطريق
الارخص كلفه لهم هل الرساله موجهه تحديدا
لرومانيا هنا اقصد استهداف هذا الميناء
نهر الدانوب المطل على رومانيا بنا
اسماعيل
في الحقيقه رومانيا تعيش حاله امان لا نمر
بايه مشاكل الان
والرغم قربي
الميناين اللذين تعرضا للهجوم وايضا
الميناء اسماعيل ايضا نحن في وضع امن ولا
علاقه لنا بالحرب علاوه على كوننا بلدا
عضوا في حلف النيتو هل سيتواصل تدفق
الحبوب عبر الموانئ الرومانيه برغم هذه
العمليه الاخيره باعتقادك
الحقيقه ونحن نتكلم الان
[موسيقى]
لم لا يواصل عمله
وحتى الميناء اسماعيل ايضا في حاله من
التوقف لكن في نفس الوقت نرى ان بامكاننا
ان تذهب الى الميناء لتحميل البضائع وهم
السفن هذه لديها الرغبه في الذهاب الى
اوديسا واسماعيل لكن منذ بضعه اشهر
رومانيا والبلدان القريبه الاخرى باتت
الطريق البديل للبضائع
الاوكرانيه وايضا هذه البدائل ستكون
بمثابه المسار الذي تلجا اليه
البلدان السفن طبعا بحر زرت مغلق وايضا
في البحر الاسود
بقلايب وغيرها من الموانئ ايضا مغلقه ايضا
الاوكران في حاله اختناق
البديل هو خطوط التضامن التي نتحدث عنها
واذا ما حسبنا حجم البضاعه في العام
الماضي لراينا ان على الاقل
50% من صادراتها الحبوب الاوكرانيه
فيما يتراوح بين خمسين الى 52 مليون نحن
تعاملنا مع 27 مليون طننا من هذه البضاعه
من بوخرست سيزر جورج مدير مؤسسه سيزر
كل من
للبحر الاسود كنت معنا من بوخارست شكرا
جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى النيجر التي تشهد تحركات مكثفه
لمجموعه اكواس بعد مرور اسبوع على
الانقلاب بفرغ باجتماع رؤساء اركان في ابو
جالي بحث تطورات في البلاد تؤكد المجموعه
ان التدخل العسكري هو خيارها الاخير وترسل
وفدا لنيابي للتفاوض مع القاده العسكريين
للبلاد للوصول الى حل ينزع فتيل ازمه قد
تاخذ بعدا اقليميا ودوليا
وزراء دفاع الايكواس في عاصمه نيجيريا
لمناقشه انماط التعامل مع قاده الانقلاب
في نيامه يجتمعون لكن النبره التهديد
بتدخل العسكري تتراجع فخمسه من اعضاء
المنظمه يقودها انقلابيون في النهايه مفوض
الكواس للشؤون السياسيه عبد الفتاح موسى
قال ان وفدا من المنظمه موجود في النيجر
للتفاوض مع قاده الانقلاب موسى قال كذلك
ان تدخل العسكري سيكون الخيار الاخير
النبره الهادئه جاءت بعد اعلان كل من مالي
وبوركينا فاسو انهما ستتدخلان عسكريا
لصالح الانقلابيين اذا ما تدخل الايكواس
عسكريا في النيجر
اما العالم فيتابع الازمه خوفا من تطاير
الشرر الى المنطقه الافريقيه الملتهبه
اصلا وسط كل هذا ما يزال الرئيس بازون
معزولا ومحتجزا وان كان على اتصال دائم
بالساسه والعسكريين والمنظمات الدوليه في
محاوله لاستعاده حكمه السليم
ونتعرف على نشاه مجموعه اكواس وكذلك ابرز
مهامها وتدخلاتها العسكريه في منطقه غرب
افريقيا في العرض التالي
او المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
منظمه تعاون افريقيه سياسيه واقتصاديه رات
النوره عام
1975 عندما وقعت 15 دوله افريقيه على
معاهده المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا بمدينه لاجوس في نيجيريا يبلغ
مجموع سكان الدول الخمسه عشره الاعضاء
اكثر من
349 مليونا نسمه وتبلغ مساحتها الاجماليه
اكثر من خمسه ملايين كيلومتر مربع اي 17%
من اجمالي مساحه قاره افريقيا
تقول المنظمه الواقع مقرها بالعاصمه
النيجيريه ابوجا انها تهدف الى تعزيز
التعاون والتكامل بين دورها لرفع مستويات
المعيشه لشعوبها وللمحافظه على الاستقرار
الاقتصادي بالمنطقه الميثاق التاسيسي
للمنظمه يتيح لها اتخاذ اجراءات بحق دول
اعضاء ويشكل الاقتصاد القوه الاهم لتحقيق
ذلك باعتباره وسيله لفرض العقوبات لكنه
يتيح ايضا امكانيه التدخل عسكريا عبر قوه
فصل افريقيه للتدخل وقت الازمات وتعرف
باسم قوه الايكوموك وسبق لاكواس ان
استخدمت قواتها فعده دول اما في شكل قوات
لحفظ السلام كما في الحرب الاهليه بكل من
كوت ديفوار في 2003 وليبيريا في ذات العام
او تدخل عسكري مباشر من اجل تسليم السلطه
للرئيس المنتخب وهو ما حدث في كوت ديفوار
عام 2010 واخيرا غامبيا في 2017
ورغم طموحها الكبير في تحقيق الاندماج
الاقتصادي بين دول افريقيا الغربيه اصطدمت
مجموعه الاكواس بالاضطرابات السياسيه
والامنيه بدول المنطقه وضعف بناها
الاقتصاديه الى جانب النفوذ الاجنبي بغرب
افريقيا الغني بالمواد الاوليه ومصادر
الطاقه
في هذه الاثناء قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان سفرتها في ميامي ما زالت مفتوحه وان
اتصالات دبلوماسيه مع النيجر تجري على
اعلى المستويات وقد نقلت وكاله رويترز عن
مسؤول امريكي قوله ان واشنطن تخطط لاجلاء
الموظفين غير الاساسيين من سفاراتها في
النيجر ونقل موقع بوليتيكو عن دبلوماسي
امريكي قوله ان الوضع على الارض في عاصمه
النيجر مستقر نسبيا نظيفا انه تم بالفعل
اجلاء 20 من موظفي الوكاله الامريكيه
للتنميه الدوليه هذا الاسبوع
من ابو جابر على الدكتور الكبير ادمو
الباحث المختص في الشؤون الامنيه
والاستخباراتيه في منطقه الساحل الافريقي
اهلا بك دكتور كبير
والسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه بعد هذا البيان
بعد لقاء رؤساء اركان مجموعه ايكواس هو
اصرار هذا البيان والحديث على ان التدخل
العسكري ما زال موجودا وان كان حلا اخيرا
كيف يمكن الحديث عن تدخل عسكري في ظل هذا
الانقسام في داخل اكواس
[موسيقى]
اذا تذكرتم في الاسبوع الماضي كيف ان
الرؤساء البلدان التي هي من ضاويه تحت
روايه الاكواس عقدوا قمه واصدروا بيانا
ختابيا قالوا فيه ان هناك احتمال ان يكون
هناك تدخل عسكريا في النيجر كما اشاروا
الى ان رؤساء الاركان سيلتقون لمده ثلاثه
ايام لوضع الاستراتيجيات اللازمه لاي تدخل
عسكري اذا لقاء اليوم بين رؤساء الاركان
كان نتيجه
لقمه الرؤساء وسوف ينتهي يوم الجمعه لانه
لقاء من المزمع ان يستمر ثلاثه ايام
لرؤساء اركان كل دول الاكواس ولوضع
الاستراتيجيات نحن نعلم ان عشر بلدا من
بين خمسه عشر حضر اللقاء مالي غينيا
وغينيا قناكري
وغينيا
وبوركينا فاسو لم تحضر الاجتماع ولكن
مواقف هذه الدول التي ذكرتها
واضح اي تدخل عسكري في النيجر هو تدخل ضد
هذه الدول اذا ما اضفنا لها ايضا بعض
الدول الاقليميه ترفض اي عمل عسكري في
النيجر وبالتالي كيف يمكن تصور فكره تدخل
عسكري من قبل الاكواس في ظل هذه الظروف
والمعطيات
الفرق في الرغبه من اجل وجود حكومه
ديمقراطيه
وسلام وامن مستتب في المنطقه
كتحديات تواجه المنطقه اربعه بلدان
بوركينا فاسو مالي غينيا وغينيا
كلها تواجهه تحديات امنيه في حاله بوركينا
فاسو تقريبا ما بين 50 الى 70 من البلد
يخضع تحت سيطره فراعل من غير الدوله اضافه
الى مالي وايضا
تحكمها طغم انقلابيه عسكريه هم من الصعب
ان نرى ان هذه البدايه ستستطيع التحدي
اراده اكوس نحن هنا نتحدث عن احد عشر بلدا
مدعومه من المجتمع الدولي كلها تلتئمه
سويه لاصدار موقف
موحد لهذا السبب اربعه بلدان حتى مع
مجموعه
الموجوده في مالي في بوركينا فاسو والتي
اذا ما قررت دعم هذه البلدان الثلاثه
والاربعه نعم سيكون هناك تحدي
لاكواس ورغبتها في التدخل العسكري ايضا ما
يثير الاهتمام ان الجزائر اصدرت بيانا من
وزاره خارجيتها
عبر عن عدم دعمها لاي تدخل عسكري اذا يمكن
ان نرى موقفا تتطور فيه الازمه الى ما
وراء المنطقه وسيكون تتحول الى ازمه
تتجاوز تداعياتها من غرب افريقيا لتشمل
عموم القاره الافريقيه من ابو جاء الدكتور
الكبير ادموه والباحث المختص في شؤون
الامنيه والاستخباريه في منطقه الساحل
الافريقي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وصف وزير الخارجيه الافغاني امير خان متقي
في مقابله مع الجزيره وصف المفاوضات التي
جرت مؤخرا في الدوحه مع الوفد الامريكي
وصفها بالايجابيه جدا واضاف متقي انه تم
تاكيد خلال المفاوضات على احترام واشنطن
سياده افغانستان
الامريكي لمده يومين متتاليين
والمفاوضات انتهتانيهم بصوره رائعه وكانت
الاجواء ايجابيه جدا
واستمعنا الى قلقهم
وهم ايضا يستمعون الى افكارنا
ومقترحاتنا وحسب اتفاق الدوحه على
الولايات المتحده تحترم السياده الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
كما قال وزير الخارجيه الافغاني في مقابله
مع الجزيره ان افغانستان تريد حل ملف
المعتقلين الاجانب لديها بطريقه ترضي كل
الاطراف
الاجراءات
وفي افغانستان
لديها قواعد ومبادئ وانها تتعامل يعني
بناء على هذه هذا الوصول والقواعد مع
العالم واذا يكون هناك مواطنين اجانب
معتقلين في افغانستان
ولكننا نريد ان نحل من هذه المشكله وهذا
الملف بصوره يعني يناسب لكلا الطرفين
كما طالب وزير الخارجيه الافغاني الولايات
المتحده برفع العقوبات عن افغانستان وحل
قضيه الاموال المجمده لديها
لدينا قنوات
وهناك اليه واضحه
للجلوس والمفاوضات
الولايات المتحده قمنا بمناقشه
قضيه البنوك وعلى الولايات المتحده ان
ترفع العقوبات حتى تتمكن البنوك الافغانيه
من ارسال واستقبال اموال وايضا تطرقنا الى
اموال المجمده في البنوك الامريكيه
والاجنبيه هو ان يتمكن البنك الوطني من
التصرف في الاموال الموجوده لدى الولايات
المتحده
مشاهدينا الكرام الى ان مقابله وزير
الخارجيه لامير خان مرتقي مع الجزيره ستبث
على شاشتنا كامله في نشره منتصف الليل
بتوقيت مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث قرر الرئيس قيس سعيد اقاله
رئيسه الحكومه نجلاء مدن وتعيين احمد
الحشاني خلفا لها وقال سعيد ان هناك
تحديات كبيره تواجه الحكومه ابرزها محاربه
ما سماه اللوبيات التي تحاول تجويع الشعب
ومن جانبها شككت جبهه الخلاص في قانونيه
قرار سعيد اقاله بودن
رئيس حكومه جديد يخلف نجلاء بودن بعد
عامين من الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اتخذها الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
درس القانون وشغل منصبا في البنك المركزي
التونسي لكن لم يكن للرجل نشاط سياسي او
حزبي يذكر
صعيد خلال استقباله لبودن والحشاني اشار
الى تحديات عده تواجهها البلاد
التحديات اليوم التي نواجهها
تحديات كبيره
رفعنا بعضها ولكن ما زال امامنا الطريق ما
زالت هذه الطريق طويله
ولن نتردد في العمل من اجل الاستجابه
لاراده شعبنا
تسرعت ردود الفعل على التعيين الاخير بعض
الاطراف المواليه لسعيد انتقدت القرار
نظرا الى طبيعه المرحله التي تحتاج برايها
الى حكومه سياسيه
بينما تحفظت المعارضه على القرار ووصفته
بالغامض
وضعيه لا تبعث على التفاؤل دون عايشه ازمه
كبرى الصفه الاساسيه نتاع التعامل هي
الانكار الدوله لا تريد ان تقول باننا في
حاله افلاس وبان الاولويه هي معالجه مساله
لم تقدم السلطاته مبرراتها لتغيير رئاسه
الحكومه لكن انتقادات سعيد لاداء
المسؤولين تكررت في الاونه الاخيره خاصه
في ظل نقص وفقدان عدد من المواد الاساسيه
والمدعومه وعلى راسها الحبوب
حيث تشهد المخابز التوابير لم تحدها تونس
من قبل اضافه الى الانقطاع المتكرر للماء
والكهرباء عوامل دفعت صعيد وفق البعض الى
اتخاذ هذه الخطوه
هو اعتراف بالفشل وبالتالي هنا وفي ظل
الوضع الاقتصادي تقريبا الصعب في ظل معنا
الطوابير التي نراها الى غير ذلك فبالتالي
لابد من احداثها سياسيه قد تحدث يعني نوع
من التغيير او هناك رغبه من التغيير ربما
وكانت حكومه نجلاء بودن قد فشلت في التوصل
الى اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي تحصل من
خلاله تونس على قرض يمكنها من شراء المواد
الاساسيه ويحسن الاوضاع المعيشيه
للتونسيين
بتعيين رئيس جديد للحكومه يتخذ قيس سعيد
خطوه جديده لمواجهه التحديات الكبيره كما
يصفها تحديات سياسيه واقتصاديه ومعيشيه
عززت من الانتقادات التي صدرت من الموالين
قبل المعارضين لسياسات الرئيس التونسي
وحكومته الجزيره
تونس
[موسيقى]
في السودان دقت الامم المتحده ناقوس خطر
بشان احتمال تعرض البلاد ازمه جوع وشيكا
حيث قال نائب المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده فرحان حق ان اكثر من سته
ملايين شخص في السودان على بعد خطوه واحده
من المجاعه بسبب الصراع المتواصل
الشؤون الانسانيه من ان الجوع والنزوح
بسبب الحرب المستمره يخرج عن نطاق السيطره
اكثر من سته ملايين شخص في السودان على
بعد خطوه واحده من المجاعه كما يواجه اكثر
من 20 مليون شخص في جميع انحاء البلاد
مستويات عاليه من انعدام الامن الغذائي
الحاد ويرجع ذلك الى الصراع والتدهور
الاقتصادي والنزوح الجماعي
في الاثناء تتواصل المعارك في مناطق عده
من البلاد حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
الجيش وجه قصفا مدفعيا من منطقه كرر
العسكريه شمالي مدينه ام درمان تجاه مواقع
الدعم السريع وسط وجنوب ام درمان في غضون
ذلك قال مصدر في الجيش السوداني للجزيره
ان قوات العمل الخاص التابعه لمنطقه ام
درمان العسكريه نفذت هجوما على ما سماها
مخابئ الميليشيا المتمرده داخل منازل
المواطنين
[موسيقى]
وفي شمال كردفان غرب كردفان غربي البلاد
اصدر الوالي امرا يقضي بفرض حظر للتجوال
داخل الحدود الجغرافيه لولايه شمال كردفان
ابتداء من الساعه السابعه مساء وحتى
الخامسه صباحا الا لضروره ملح
من جهتها حذرت قوات الدعم السريه من نشوب
ما وصفته بالحرب الاهليه بين مكونات شرق
السودان وان ملامحها بدات بتسليح بعض
القبائل مما يعد خطرا على النسيج
الاجتماعي وقال بيان صادر عن الدعم السريع
ان تحركات العالميه لقيادات المؤتمر
الوطني شرقي السودان تتم بعلم الاستخبارات
العسكريه وفق ما جاء في البيان
سياسيا قال الناطق الرسمي للجيش السوداني
ان الحديث عن هدنه مزعجه غير صحيح او عفوا
خذنا مزعومه غير صحيح واضاف ان وفد
التفاوض لا يزال في السودان وان التفاوض
متوقف
تابع هذه الكلمه المباشره لقائد ما يسمى
بالمجلس الانتقالي في السودان يعني
اذا نتابع هذه الكلمه لقائد الانقلاب في
النيجر عبد الرحمن
في مكافحتنا ضد الارهاب
والافات الاخرى الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
والتي تقود النمو في النيجر
اعزائي النجريين والنيجريات بالنسبه الى
عمليه
المحاسبه يجب الله يتم
الحديث عن النظام الذي سقط لان العداله هي
الاساس ويجب ان لا نضيف المصاعب بشكل
اضافي على كاهل الشعب النيجري وكان هناك
سوء تفسير واستغلال من قبل كل اولئك الذين
لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي من ولاء وطني
وبرايهم يمكنهم ان يقودوا العمليه
الانتقاليه في بلادنا في الحقيقه لقد
شاهدنا بعض الناس الذين هاجمونا وكان هناك
نقص في التنسيق بين وجه الامني
والدفاعي باضافه الى غياب
النظره الى الامور التي تحدثوا عنها ولكن
من خلال هذا العمل
تمكنا من تكذيب ما قالوه
وسمحنا للشعب النيجيري ان يفهم ان عملنا
تم لمصلحه الشعب النيجري
قوات الدفاع والامن التزمت بعملنا وذلك من
خلال
القياده وبعد البيان الذي صدر عن رئاسه
الاركان
وبحضور كل القاده العسكريين النيجيريين
الى جانبنا قوات الدفاع في النيجر لم
تنقسم ولن تتقاتل
لايات سياسيه ان عائلتنا الكبيره من قوات
الدفاع وقوات الامن تسعى الى تامين الامني
في النيجر وجميعنا نواجه العدو فيه
الميدان ونقدم التضحيات الكبرى
لاضافه الى ذلك الشعب النيجيريا طالما
اصطف الى جانب الجيش وقوات الدفاع والامن
ان قوات الدفاع والامن تمخضت عن اراده
الشعب النيجيري والذي يمكنه ان يعتمد
عليها في اصعب واحلك الظروف كلا الشعب في
النيجر لن يكون دائما او ابدا عفوا في وجه
قوات الدفاع والامن
ان قوات الدفاع والامن لديها تاريخ
طويل من العيش بوئام على المستوى
الاجتماعي ونسجي العلاقات العائليه
الاسريه
وحمل القيم الافريقيه النيجيريه والدينيه
والمصلحه الوطنيه
الاعزاء الناجرين كما يمكنكم ان تروه ما
من ما من عاملا سياسيا داخلي يمكنه ان يقف
في وجه عمل الانتقالي لمصلحه النيجر هذا
امل باتجاه تغيير حقيقي لمقاربتنا في
كفاحنا الوطني للحفاظ على سياده دولتنا
وهذا ما سوف نعمل عليه ولن نخون ثقه الشعب
في النيجر الذي يسعى الى تامين حياه امنه
من خلال ارساء هذه
الحكومه الجديده نعمل على العمليه
الانتقاليه وتاكدوا ان شاء الله انه
وبدعمكم نحن شعب النيجر السيد سوف نستمر
في عملنا
لخدمه النيجر ولذلك اطلب منكم ان تثقوا
بالمجلس الوطني
لحمايه الوطن بالنسبه الى هذه النقطه
المواطنون والمواطنات الاعزاء
الشعب النيجري لا يعارض استلام المجلس
زمام السلطه من اجل انقاذ البلاد اكثريه
الشعب قدمت دعم للمجلس الوطني
لحمايه وانقاذ الوطن منذ
السادس والعشرين من يوليو 2023 شاهدنا
التحركات بالالاف دعما للمجلس ودعمنا
لقوات الدفاع والامن المعارضه تاتي من قبل
بعض الاشخاص الذين يفكرون ان باستطاعتهم
ان يؤثروا سلبا على الدوله النيجيريه
والتي والذين لديهم اصطفافات خارجيه
لاضافه الى ذلك عدد من شركائنا في الكفاح
ضد الارهاب وعدد من قاده الدول
الذين يحاولون ان يستغلوا ويسيسوا
المؤسسات لموارب شخصيه اعزائي النيجيريين
في مواجهه هذه التدخلات الخارجيه لقد
تفاجانا شاننا شان معظم الشعب النيجيري في
وجه هذه
الاعتراضات على استلام المجلس زمام السلطه
لمصلحه شعب النيجر
ودعوات التي
وصلتنا ضد هذه العمليه الانتقاليه هذه هذه
السلوكيات لا تاتي بالفائده لا للسلطه
الجديده من قبل المجلس ولا في عمليه
مكافحتنا
للارهاب حيث ان ذلك يبث الشقاق
وانعدام الثقه بين الشركاء والعمل مع
المجتمع الدولي في منطقه الساحل ولكن اكثر
من كل شيء يطرح سلسله من الاسئله امام
الشعب النيجيري
كيف يمكننا ان نساعد النيجر في مواجهه
الارهاب من خلال ايقاف المساعدات العسكريه
كيف لنا ان نشرح ان الشركاء
يتخذون القرار بوقف المساعدات
من هذه الكلمه لقائد الانقلاب في الهجره
عبد الرحمن
وهي كلمه يبدو انها موجهه لشعب النيجر
لمدعاه الاتفاف لما سماه المجلس الوطني
لحمايه الوطن وكذلك لاطراف خارجيه
قبل الحصاد كنت قد اجريت مقابله مع عبد
الله باتيلي الممثل الخاص لامير العام
الامم المتحده في ليبيا وسالته في البدايه
عن منطق تحفظاته بخصوص القوانين
الانتخابيه
اولا انا رحبت بمسوداتي القوانين التي
افرزتها لجنه 6 + 6
كحقيقه الفرق الفنيه التي
ذهبت الى ابو زنيقه مع خمسه زائدا خمسه
وهي قدمت المساعده طيله
المداولات التي تمت نقلها لهذا السبب
السته زائد سته
مقترحات قوانينها يمكن ان تعتبر خطوه الى
الامام لكن مع ذلك عندما ننظر الى هذه
القوانين نحن عبرنا عن بعض التعليقات
وايضا اللجنه العليا للانتخابات هي التي
ايضا بدورها نظرت الى هذه القوانين
وعدد من الناس الذين تفحصوا هذه القوانين
ادرك هذه القوانين بالشكل التي
هي عليه لا تعتبر كافيه لتقود ليبيا الى
الانتخابات وهي بحاجه الى تعديلات في بعض
مقتضياتها ونصوصها والى تنقيه المال بعض
هذه النصوص لهذا السبب اليوم ارى انه من
الاهميه بمكان لكل الجهات المعنيه واصل
اصحاب المصلحه بالطبع سته زائدا سته
والبرلمانيون ان يفحصوا هذه القوانين
ويجعلوها قابله للتطبيق لان هذه قضيه مهمه
فهناك بعض البنود التي قد تخلق صراعات في
العمليه السياسيه قبل او اثناء او بعد
الانتخابات وعلاوه على ذلك انا مازلت على
قناعه بان العمليه الانتخابيه عمليه
سياسيه شامله وهناك بعد قانوني
وهناك ايضا بعد سياسي محض لها كما تعلمون
فان القوانين الانتخابيه التي افرزتها سته
زائدا سته دعت الى اصلاحي الحكومه الجديده
وهذه ليست قضيه قانونيه فحسب بل هي قضيه
سياسيه ايضا لهذا السبب نحن اعذرني على
المقاطعه السيد عبد الله باشاره للبعد
السياسي ايضا هل لك ان تشرح لنا عن قولك
بان جهود الحل في ليبيا لا يجب ان تقتصر
فقط على مجلسي النواب والدوله هل لك ان
تشرح ما هي الاطراف الاخرى
كما قلت هناك البعد القانوني للانتخابات
وكما كنت احاول ان اشرح ذلك لكم لكن البعد
القانوني ليس كافيا البعد السياسي مهم
ايضا لان القضايا السياسيه الشائكه تبقى
كما تعلمون الازمه موجوده منذ 12 عاما
وكما لاحظتم انه قبل نحو عامين من الان تم
تشكيل حكومه جديده والان لدينا حكومتان في
ليبيا ان من المهم حل هذه القضيه قضيه
الحكومتين وان يكون هناك
مشاركه من كل الاطراف المعنيه في العمليه
السياسيه لتتوصل الى اتفاق شامل بين
اللاعبين الرئيسيين وليس فقط بين مجلس
الدوله ومجلس النواب لكن من قبل
القاده الاخرين والقاده
قاده المؤسسات الاخرى وان يكون هناك اطار
قانوني يكون مقبولا من قبل
الغالبيه من الفواعل السياسيه
هذه الاطراف الرئيسيه عفوا او اللاعبين
الرئيسيين كما قلت الان السيد عبد الله من
هم
الليبيا في ليبيا اليوم لديك على الاقل
خمسه لاعبين اساسيين موجودون على الارض
بالطبع لدي لديكم المنزل على الدوله
والبرلمان
وايضا لديك
المجلس الرئاسي المنسي الرئاسي بادر من
جانبه لبحث كل مع الاطراف المعنيه
الرئيسيه لتشكيل لجنه ماليه من شانها ان
ترعى انفاق الدوله وهذا امر متفق عليه بين
اللاعبين الرئيسيين لكن هناك ايضا قضيه
الحكومه
فلذلك اللاعبون الاخرون لديك الحكومه
الموجودتان حاليا ولكن لديك ايضا
اللاعبين امنيين عندما نتحدث عن
الانتخابات فنحن نريد اليه لحفظ الامن
ولهذا السبب قبل بضعه اشهر نحن بدانا
بمناقشه ومن خلال عمليه حواريه بين الخمسه
زائدا خمسه
والشخصيات الفاعله في الامن في ليبيا من
كل الانحاء ليستمعوا سويه ويبحث قضيه
تامين العمليه الانتخابي اذا كل هؤلاء
اللاعبين مهمون
لتامين اليه سلام من خلال حل الازمه في
لبنان
عبد الله وبالتالي هل تتوقعون يكون هناك
تجاوب او استجابه لهذه الرغبه بالجلوس
تحديدا مثلا من قبل مجلسي النواب لهذه
الدعوه والجلوس والنقاش هل تتوقعون تجاوبا
ايجابيا
ايضا ومن الان استجابه ايجابيه من بعض
اللاعبين وهو مهم حتى في يومنا هذا وانا
اتحدث اليكم في هذه اللحظه لدينا مناقشات
مثمره مع رئيس البرلمان عقيل صالح
غدا سارتقي خالد المشري وفي الايام
القادمه
سالتقي بقيه الفراعة الرئيسية لان الازمه
في ليبيا متعدده الاوجه والطبقات انا
دائما اتحدث معهم لكن من المهم في هذه
اللحظه الزمنيه المازق الذي وصلنا اليه
يجد له حلا وان نلتمس طرقا وسبلا
للتوصل الى حل سلمي والى اطار قانوني
سياسيا كل الاطراف المعنيه تقبل به وتشارك
فيه مجموعه العمل الامنيه المنبثقه عن
مؤتمر برلين وبالنظر للوضع المتفاقم في
السودان قالت ان ما يجري في السودان عقدت
الجانب الامني فيما يتعلق بموضوع المرتزقه
وانسحاب هذه المجموعات الى اي مدى هذا
المعطى عقد حساباتكم فيما يتعلق بايجاد حل
في ليبيا
نحن
[موسيقى]
المقتنعون بان الازمه في السودان قد يكون
لها افرازات تشمل ليبيا لكن مع ذلك في شهر
مارس الماضي وفي بدايات شهر ابريل انا زرت
السودان وزرتشاد وزرت النيجر
للبحث مع قاده هذه البلدان قضايا انسحاب
المقاتلين الاجانب والمرتزقه بالطبع الوضع
الحالي في هذه البلدان السودان
يمكن اصبحت اكثر تعقيدا لكن نحن نرى ان ان
الازمه في السودان
ستنتهي قريبا وكذلك الاحداث الراهنه في
النيجر ستنتهي لكن مع ذلك من الاهميه لنا
مستمره في
نقاشاتنا مع قاده هذه البلدان وقد اسسنا
لجنه التواصل
لترسم ملامحه
خاصه بالتعامل مع التشكيلات المسلحه في
ليبيا والتي اصلها من هذه البلدان وقد
جعلنا من لجنه التنسيق هذه في ليبيا
تتواصل مع اللجنه 5 + 5
ولجان النظراء لها من هذه البلدان والعمل
من بين اللجان تلك البلدان واللجنه
التنسيق التي شكلناها مهمه في ضوء حل جهود
حل الازمه الليبيه لهذا السبب اقول لكم ان
الازمه في ليبيا لا يمكن ان تحلى من خلال
اليه قانونيه فحاسب بل تحتاج الى اليه
سياسيه واقتصاديه وغيرها لهذا السبب يجب
ان نحل القضايا الامنيه لعقل الوقت واعتذر
منك كنت مع المقر بعثه الامم المتحده في
طرابلس المبعوث الامم الى ليبيا السيد عبد
الله بتيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في فقره المتابعه نسلط الضوء على تكرار
استهداف روسيا موانئ اوكرانيه بديله
لتصدير الحبوب منذ انسحابها من اتفاق
الدولي يسمع بالمرور الامن لصادرات الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود الى الاسواق
العالميه في احدث هجوم من نوعه دمر طائرات
مسيره روسيه قادمه من البحر الاسود بونان
تحتيه تابعه لميناء اسماعيل الواقع في
مقاطعه اوديسا والمطل على نهر الدانوب
قباله سواحل رومانيا ونهر الدانوب اصبح
طريق تصدير رئيسي للحبوب الاوكرانيه بعد
اعاده موسكو فرض حصارها الفعلي على موالي
اوكرانيا المطله على البحر الاسود في
منتصف يوليو الماضي
في موانئ يجني
واوديساورما التي كانت السفن المحمله
بالحبوب تبحر منها مرورا بمضيق الاسطور
وفيما بدا بانها محاوله اخرى للتضييق على
صادره الحبوب الاوكرانيه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تقييد حركه الملاحه في
مضيق كرش بالبحر الاسود في حين ما زال
الروس يستخدمون موانئهم المطله على البحر
الاسود وتلك الواقعه في بحر ازوف المتصل
به لايصال معظم صادراتهم من الحبوب نحو
العالم اتجهت اوكرانيا اذا الى تفعيل ما
تسمى الموالي النهريه بعد فقدانها القدره
على استخدام ممر البحر الاسود لتصدير
الحبوب من موانئك هناك بشكل امن لكن روسيا
تعمل على افساد تلك الخطه البديله وتقول
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ان الضربات الجويه
الروسيه دمرت نحو 180 الف طن مت من محاصيل
الحبوب الاوكرانيه في اقل من اسبوعين
الرئيس
الاوكرانيس في اعتبرها من جانبه ان
الهجمات الروسيه المتكرره على الموانئ
وصوامع الحبوب في اوديسا تستهدف الامناء
الغذائي اذن تضرر الامن الغذائي ايضا بحسب
كيان بعد تعطيل موسكو اتفاق الحبوب الذي
مكن من تصدير نحو 33 مليون طن من الحبوب
الاوكرانيه على مدار عام معلوم ايضا انه
بانسحابها من الاتفاق كثفت روسيا هجماتها
على صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه وجددت
حصارها لموانئ اوكرانيا المطله على البحر
الاسود لفهم هذا التطور العسكري الروسي
فيما يتعلق فيما يمكن تسميته بحرب الحبوب
نستضيف معنا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز
ماذا تريد موسكو بتوسيع
اهدافها فيما يمكن تسميته بحرب الحبوب
يعني هناك اكثر من سبب من كقراءه سريعه
عمليه مهاجمه الموانع سواء التي التقى على
البحر الاسود او التي تقع على نهر الدانوب
نجدها تزامنت مع امرين محددين الامر الاول
مهاجمه جسر القرم للمره الثانيه والتي
تزامنت مع انتهاء فتره او اتفاقيه تمديد
الحبوب
وكان هناك اضافه ثالثه تكثيف الهجمات
بالطائرات المسيره على شبه جزيره القرم
وعلى
موسكو سيتي او موسكو سنتر
ومدينه موسكو بصوره عامه
وبالتالي صدور بيانات
كان اخرها من الرئيس يتحدث بصوره عامه عن
نقل المعركه الى الداخل الروسي
ومهاجمه اهداف ذات قيمه رمزيه هذه العوامل
بمجملها
ادت بروسيا لعمليه تنفيذ هذه الضربات لان
هذه الضربات تحقق لروسيا ابعادا كثيره قد
تكون ورقه مقايضه من اجل السماح بتصدير
الاسمده والحبوب الروسيه بناء على الاتفاق
الاول قد تحد من استخدام اوكرانيا
للطائرات المسيره والصواريخ في قصف جزيره
القرم قد تحد من امكانيه استخدام موسكو
لان هذه الاستخدامات لها مدلولات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه والنفسيه وبالتالي اي عوده
واي عوده لتفعيل هذه الاتفاقيه يجب ان من
وجهه نظري ستطلب روسيا من اوكرانيا ان
تقدم تنازلات في البعد العسكري فيما يتعلق
بشبه جزيره القرم وفيما يتعلق باستخدام
المسيرات في العمق الروسي والى مدينه
موسكو باستهداف على سبيل المثال ميناء
اسماعيل في نهر الدانوب بالقرب من الحدود
الرومانيه هل هي ايضا رساله خارجيه
يعني لا هذه كمان هي ورقه ضغط قد تكون
رساله خارجيه التقارير متباينه التقرير
الذي عرض تحدث عن ثلاثين مليون طن بعض
التقارير تحدثت عن 49.5 مليون طن واحد
التقارير اطلعت عليه تحدث عن 65 مليون طن
التي تم تصديرها وهذا التقرير كان تفصيليا
بحيث ذكر ان اثنين وثلاثين مليون طن صدرت
عبر البحر الاسود وعشرين مليون طن عبر نهر
الدانوب وعشره مليون طن عبر السكك
الحديديه وثلاثه مليون طن بوسائل اخرى اذا
يعتبر نهر الدانوب اذا كان هذا التقرير
دقيق في محتوى يعتبر بديل فاعل بدل البحر
الاسود فيما اذا تم محاصره الموانئ لفتره
طويله اذا المقاطعه
الان عن فاعليه هذه الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
في ظل الاصرار الاوكراني بانها ستواصل
تصدير الحبوب
في هذا اليوم تم توقيع بروتوكول اولي مع
مع كرواتيا
للاستفاده من موانئ كرواتيا على نهر
الدانوب اي بمعنى اخر ان نهر الدانوب
سيبقى رغم المهاجمه لميناء اسماعيل سيبقى
احد البدائل الرئيسيه ستبقى السكك
الحديديه وستبقى الوسائل الاخرى لكن في
نقطه يجب ان اشير لها عمليه استخدام نهر
الدانوب وخاصه العبور القطعي وليس الابحار
الطولي من الجانب الاوكراني الى الجانب
الروماني اثار حافظه المزارعين في رومانيا
وبلغاريا لانه انعكس سلبا على المزارعين
بسبب تدني اسعار الحبوب في تلك البلدان
اذا هناك العديد من التقاطعات لابد من
مراعاتها جميعا من عمان اللواء فايزه
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نكتب هذا الحصاد بشكوى يبثها الكثيرون نحن
وانتم ربما الجميع من الوقت الطويل الذي
يمضيه يمضيه الابناء على اجهزتهم
الالكترونيه وتدعي ذلك بدنيا ونفسيا وكذلك
اجتماعيا تم تحل على الطريقه الصينيه ايضا
هذه المره بغض النظر عن الاختلاف او
الاتفاق حول تفاصيلها فبموجب قانون جديد
لمكافحه الادمان على الانترنت كشف النقاب
عنه هذا اليوم سيمنع الصينيون الذين تقل
اعمارهم عن 18 عاما قريبا من استخدام
الانترنت ليلا على هواتفهم الذكيه فيما
سيصبح الوقت اليومي الذي يمضونه على
الشبكه محدودا بمقتضى هذا القانون وينص
القانون ايضا الذي يفترض ان يدخل يفترض ان
يدخل حيز التنفيذ بعد شهر من الان على منع
اي قاصر من استخدام الانترنت عبر اي جهاز
محمول بين الساعه العاشره مساء والسادسه
صباحا ويمكن للاباء ايقاف تشغيل هذه
الميزات في حال رغبوا في ذلك القواعد
والصينيه تبدو الاكثر صرامه في العالم في
هذا الخصوص لكن علينا ايضا تذكر الاثار
المدمره لما بات يعرف بالادمان على
الانترنت اذا امنع ابنائك بمقتضى القانون
كما جاء في القانون الصيني هذا كنا في
حصادنا هذا اليوم دمتم بخير مباشره الى
جوله منتصف الليل يرافقكم فيها وسيله علمي
وعبد السلام محمد